كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني حاله تاهب الجوي
في عموم البلاد بسبب اقلاع طائره حربيه من
اراضي بيلاروسيا وافاد مراسل الجزيره
باستمرار القصف الروسي على مقاطعه
ونقل مراسلنا عن سلطات المقاطعه الجنوبيه
ان الروس شنوه خلال ساعات الماضيه اكثر من
50 هجوما على عموم اراضي المقاطعه
بالمدفعيه وصواريخ جراد كما قال هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت
خلال الساعات الماضيه 20 غاره واكثر من 90
رشقه صاروخيه على مقاطعات عده ما اوقع
قتلى وجرحى في صفوف المدنيين
على الجانب الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا قالت
السلطات المحليه المواليه لموسكو مدنيا
قتل واصيب اربعه بجروح جراء قصف اوكراني
استهدف مقاطعه دنيا خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
واشارت السلطات المواليه لروسيا الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت سبعه احياء سكنيه
باكثر من 150 قذيفه ما الحق اضرارا بمبان
سكنيه عده ومرافق البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
وفي داخل الاراضي الروسيه اعلن حكيم منطقه
الروسيه المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت منشاه صناعيه
في مدينه
بوريسوفكا وقال
قوه الاطفاء تمكنت من السيطره على الحريق
دون وقوع اصابات بفضل اخلاء المنشاه من
العاملين في الوقت المناسب واضاف ان
الاقليم سيدخل من اليوم المستوى الاصفر من
التهديد الارهابي الى اجل غير مسمى واوضح
انه سيتم رفع اثار هذا الاجراء حينما
يتحسن الوضع